[Music]
hey guys this is Adam with farm life
Outfitters and I just wanted to jump on
here today and and talk to you a little
bit about our cows we purchased our
first cows this year so this is year one
with them and we've learned a lot we
have enjoyed them I just I love having
the cows they're they're easy to manage
they they're just a pleasure to be
around the only con is that they eat a
lot they do require quite a bit of food
compared to what we've had in the past
with our sheep and goats so I had to buy
quite a bit of hay this year and they
require a lot of pasture so I want to
talk to you about a little experiment
that I'm doing right now with managed
grazing compared to continuous grazing
so here we go alright so from about
September I don't know early September
through October we did not have much
rain at all and so I I kept our cows
over here close to the house and fed
them hay during that time to keep them
off the pasture so over here one of our
pastures is approximately five acres and
it looks something like this
I think you guys saw me splitting this
up into paddocks earlier in the year so
it looks something like this and then we
have a divider that looks something like
that
so we separated the entire pasture into
two two patches basically so the total
total is about five acres for this
entire plot so from the end of August
till November there were there were no
animals on this pasture which allowed
the grass to regrow and before I took
the cows over I mean it was probably a
foot tall in some places or maybe more
in the grass so well November the 10th I
moved the cows over here and and I've
setting up a daily rotation which looks
like this
so everyday I will set this up these
three wires get set up everyday so
they're here on day one then they move
here and then this wire gets moved to
here so the next day they moved here and
so on and so on so I've calculated that
by keeping this these paddocks tight
I've got 50 days worth of grazing in
this in this five acres I am new to this
I'm new to having cows I'm still
figuring out how to move in that what to
do
and we also forgot to tell you how many
we have so we have six cows we have
three calves and one ball
so I've calculated that this five acres
will last 50 days by moving them every
day from paddock to paddock on the other
hand and this is the part of the
experiment that I'm sort of guessing at
I mean I can I can look at the patch
during kind of tale how long it might
last so I have estimated that if I were
to turn the cows out into this five
acres with no divisions just let them
have the entire five acres my estimation
would be that it would last two weeks so
continuous grazing would last two weeks
with no hay so that would mean out of
the fifty days they would be here I
would have to feed hay for five weeks
and from having them close to the house
and feeding them hey I have found that
they will go through a roll of hay in
three to four days so let's just say
every four days we need a roll of hay
so that would be nine rules well that
would be a cost of three hundred and
fifteen dollars for continuous grazing
that's two weeks with no hay in five
weeks
feeding hay and feeding out nine rolls
of hay during that time let's compare
that to managed intensive grazing by
moving them every day and giving them
just enough for that day all right so I
am like I said I'm moving the cows but
I'm also giving them some hay and I
found that for let's just call it
managed intensive grazing MiG one roll
of hay will last two weeks and that's
giving them just enough every day just
to make sure they get enough to eat
and so one roll will last two weeks so
that means in 50 days I will have fed
out three and a half rolls of hay times
$35 is a hundred and twenty-five dollars
that's the cost feeding the cows during
this 50 days
so we have $315 for continuous grazing -
$125 is a balance of a hundred and
ninety dollars savings
for moving the cows everyday so after I
figured that I wanted to see how much
like you know it takes time to move
these cows so it takes me on the average
20 minutes per day so that's every
morning I go and I give the cows a
little bit of hay which takes about 10
minutes and then every afternoon I go
and move the cows to the next paddock
which takes about 10 minutes so on
average I spend 20 minutes a day feeding
and moving the cows so - 20 minutes a
day that is 16 and a half hours roughly
during this 50-day pasture rotation I've
got 16 and a half hours labor and moving
the cows so then we do $190 divided by
16 and a half hours so I make $11.50 an
hour to go move the cows so to me that's
worth it that's worth it not only am i
saving money to go move the cows it's
also benefiting the land by moving the
cows I've noticed that I'm spreading the
fertility where I wanted because if if
they were continuous grazing over this
whole pasture they would pick a spot
let's say there's a tree here the tree
here that you know they would pick these
spots that they would lounge every day
and that's where most of the manure
would be deposited and that's where the
fertility would would go but by moving
them every day
this whole paddock right here is covered
with manure and then the next day this
whole paddock is just covered in manure
so on and so on so I am spreading out my
fertility over the whole pasture instead
of concentrating it in this one area
where they like to
every day another benefit that I've
noticed even though we're in fall winter
and the temperatures are pretty cold
you know we're we've gotten down into
the 20s but most days it's lows in the
30s and highs in the 60s so I've noticed
that by the time I get here which is
this is about three weeks this grass
back here is already grown back so once
I keep going going around I can come
back again and make the paddock a little
bigger you know maybe make this area
their paddock for the day or I can just
give them out the whole pasture at that
point but I think what I'm going to do
since the grass is regrowing a little
bit is just give them a slightly bigger
paddock and then just keep going around
and so instead of 50 paddocks I might
have 20 so one you know just have 20
paddocks going around so thank you for
joining me today on this little
experiment that I'm doing with the cows
like I said I really enjoy the cows I
like to see what they're doing to the
land and I'm excited to see just the
benefit of having the cows on the land
and and how much better our pastures are
going to be I hope you guys have a great
day and we'll see you on the next one
[Music]
hey will last about three weeks